hi I'm Ashley Benson and I'm at BuzzFeed
today and I'm going to be doing first
times first red carpet experience I'm
pretty sure it was a Hilary Duff movie
mm I think and it was at Universal
Studios and I was a hue imeem huge fan I
love Hillary I think I was 12 I thought
I was very cool I had no reason to walk
the red carpet and I did and I had a
horrible outfit on I'm pretty sure it
was a orange tank top with this horrible
like there was these belts that were in
like huge like thick belts I look like a
wrestler I mean it was insane
but I was very excited to do that I was
like this is basically my premiere first
crazy rumor I heard about myself it was
rumored that I dated every guy on PLL
which I dated none of them so that was a
fun one first kiss my first kiss was
actually on screen on a soap opera that
I was on and I was so terrified it was
in this party scene so there was a ton
of extras around but I was so nervous I
broke it into hives like shaking crying
and I was like everyone else to watch me
do my first kiss I didn't know what to
do but yeah it was pretty funny very
embarrassing my first bad date I've
never really been on dates so I don't
know I should I have yet to have one I
don't go on dates you know cuz I'll
never show up I make the plans and I
just cancel or I did I did do that first
member we have been working on PLL first
memory I think we're filming the pilot
we were filming in Vancouver in Canada
it was Thanksgiving in America and
obviously like they don't do that there
but we had the biggest Thanksgiving
dinner at this hotel and it was my first
night meeting all the girls and the
producers and the director it was a very
nice bonding experience and then being
freezing cold shooting outside frozen I
mean it was so hard we were in small
dresses literally about to die it was so
cold so yeah being cold and eating a ton
of Thanksgiving food first memory of
being a six chick in 3130 having to cut
bangs I cried my eyes out for days
and I tried to pin them back after I was
done filming that movie I don't know how
to do my hair
and you know I think I was 13 or 14 when
I did that it was just really hard for
me to make the bangs work and then the
growing out period was really awkward
first show you ever benched I don't
watch a lot of TV but hey myself was
right when I heard about it I spent a
whole day and watched every episode
missus Mazal I benched as well which is
really good I'm about to start euphoria
I haven't been in the country so I can
now watch HBO back here and I'm probably
gonna take a day to watch that because I
heard it's amazing well so funny enough
when I met I met her at Sara's birthday
I hadn't watched handmaids yet and my
best friend Isaac was sitting next to me
and he like started sinking in the chair
when she walked in I'm like are you okay
like what's going on he's like he's
offered its offered I was like what are
you talking about who is that what do
you mean and so that I finally he was
like I see I'm like what is he he's like
hammy so I was like okay so I call I
called him out and I was like Lizzie my
friends like obsessed with you and
freaking out and he's shaking does know
what to do so she put a napkin on her
head and become she became like offered
she was like hi Isaac and she put the
thing on
she was embarrassing if they were joking
around it was so funny he the photos in
the video you see my friend he's just
like shaking and just going in so
embarrassed
he's like why did you do that I was like
you have to say that you like the show
come on Oh first memory from moving to
New York my first memory I lived in Soho
at the time and I got this really cool
loft with my friend downstairs was a
great restaurant when my favorite
restaurants and I would just go there
every day all day I lived above it so
it's really bad cuz you just eat all the
time and drink and that's what I did
first thing you do on your phone when
you wake up first thing I do check my
messages I guess I definitely don't do
social media
my first pilla co-star you called I hang
with right now I can't choose I mean I
haven't seen Tyler and forever and like
that's my little angel baby I texted you
the other day you didn't respond Tyler
rude first cell phone my first cell
phone was a razer at the hot pink razor
and then i rhinestoned
my sidekick in all pink rinds
like who the sidekicks were insane but
it's so fun and then I got a blackberry
so I could have like bbm first project
of yours you'd rewatch right now Spring
Breakers probably first celebrity crush
hey Jonathan Taylor Thomas would be a
good one
Chad Michael Murray was it crush and
then Leonardo DiCaprio always yeah well
I uh sir of Justin Timberlake everywhere
I'd kiss him every day before I went
school first big purchase as a celebrity
a house maybe a purse I try to be really
cautious with my money this is so
embarrassing first AOL screen name
everyone's gonna hate me this is
actually embarrassing but this is how I
was was younger um it was called wish
for Fame number three really proud of
that one that is so embarrassing
first thing you kept from a set I've
never taken anything from sets and I
really I should have taken stuff from
PLL but I I would try and I'd get in
trouble so it's just I never succeeded
I'm too obvious about it also taking
like a statue I'm like no worries guys
didn't take anything first time you knew
you were famous well I don't think I'm
famous but I guess just when PLL was
kind of going off and people started
recognizing me more I was ashamed
Mitchell which is so funny for a first
time getting paparazzi and we were out
at this restaurant called boa and we
were walking in and at the time you know
your first experience is that it's like
wow this is really like cool you know so
he remember me and Shea like just
walking down the street and we knew
there was a paparazzi guy that really we
wonder if he'll know who we are because
the show had just come out and he did
and we were like strutting down the
street like so bad now I'm literally
like look like crazy and every paparazzi
been eating and like the look of us and
I hate I hate them gives me anxiety but
for that first moment I was like this is
cool and now it's just ruins do you like
my first apartment my first apartment
was in Sherman Oaks I was living with a
roommate it was the worst property you'd
ever see but we had a spiral staircase
that's the only reason I got it it's
just to go upstairs to the roof it was
horrible it was like rat-infested but I
loved it and all I did was play video
games and make cakes and order pizza
first makeup fashion moment you really
regretted all my red carpet photos from
the 2000s are really bad really bad like
I don't know what I was thinking
just look up old photos of me on red
carpets you'll see all my great choices
this is the last one we finished first
time you saw yourself in a magazine I
think it was soap opera Digest because I
was on a soap for a long time so I was
always in that I'm just for the
character and I thought it was pretty
cool okay you guys so I have a new
collection for prove a verb oh it's the
benzo collection there's three different
styles you're gonna love them here's one
of the pairs chic fun go get them I hope
you enjoy I worked in kind of hard on
them and I liked them